So you've only looked at the map, 16 states are surrounded by foreign power, unknown lands.
This is British North America, this region here is now, is new Spain.
To the south, it's Spanish Florida.
To the northwest, the territory of Oregon, which is claimed by Spain, as well as Great Britain, and even by Russia.
Oh.
Here's the vast territory of French Louisiana.
Over a hundred years ago, La Salle explored it, but the west is still unknown.
Hmm. They say the territory is desolate, no interest.
That's precisely why I am interested in knowing what is there.
For instance, are the rivers navigable? Do they lead to the Pacific for commerce?
Lewis, are you disposed to exploring the region?
I'd be delighted. What an adventure.
You realize it's dangerous.
It is said that there are wild animals and fierce tribes.
You will take 20 well-armed men with you, but always remember you are going there as friends.
The American president was unaware of the same moment that the ambassador of France was actually buying their territory.
That's the lot.
It has to be the greatest property deal ever.
200 million acres and only a few cents per acre.
Yeah, but they didn't know it at the time, so Captain Lewis' mission was to explore Movepleat, the totally unknown land.
Now, the Louisiana territory, three times bigger than France.
Master, this letter came for you, sir.
Oh, well, York, it's very good news.
Listen, my dear, my friend, Meriwether Lewis wants me to accompany him.
You're leaving again, William, but I want you back for the ball that day night.
No, that is, uh, Lewis supposes that, uh, with luck, we should make it back in three years' time.
York, you're joining the expedition, come on.
Oh, giddy-up.
That's it. Now the Louisiana Territory is a part of America, and now let's find out what we've purchased.
Monsieur Drillet will be the interpreter for the Indians.
He knows the region well.
It leads up to Yellowstone.
The latest invention!
A prefabricated craft.
A boat, you say.
And you really think it will float?
I hope it does.
Anyway, we'll soon find out.
It's the sail!
They are the Titan Zoo, and they are packed.
Stay ready, just in case.
I will try to speak to them.
Now, Code Macal.
What are they meaning?
We go power with them.
Oh-ho!
Bit of magic's always useful.
F*cking is very unhealthy.
Yes, but in this case,
you and we smoke the peace pipe,
Or it won't be terribly healthy for us either.
Wide alone.
It's for you, Great Chief.
Hmm, ah.
Does not want it.
He says that alcohol is no good medicine.
It'd make men crazy.
Yeah.
He's another Chief, and he is jealous.
He wants the gifts we gave the Big Chief.
Wow.
It's their buffalo dance.
Tomorrow the hunt, it is quite interesting.
I...
As far as I've ever gone.
...of the Missouri.
Mine is the Shoshone tribe.
They live far on the Missouri.
The tribes and their languages, I know all of them.
well would you like to come oh yes i would like to only i need the permission of charbonneau
he bought me he owns you yes yes my own tribe one day sold me to him monsieur charbonneau yes we
would like a bird woman your wife to come with us as an interpreter would you agree to this if i
come oh do you know the region like the back of my hand you're going along it's a long expedition
It might cost you a lot.
How much?
Five hundred dollars.
Truly, you drive a hard bargain.
Quite a sum.
I accept.
After two days' journey, the river divides.
We take the branch on the right.
There, you must give up your large boat.
Because of the rapids, it will not go through.
So, what do we do?
We must go in small canoes.
Great White will lend you two.
With the ones you have, it will be enough.
Really, dogs, take this one back.
Possible.
It's good.
Shoshone Country.
People, I know the passage.
We must go around the hills of the Rocky Mountains, with peaks so high no man had ever crossed them.
Now we'll need horses.
My Shoshone tribe lives there.
There are horses.
Good, we'll buy some.
Oh, we'll steal 'em.
Oh, no we won't.
We come as friends, understand?
You must shake a blanket as a sign of friendship.
And to say white man, our word is tababone.
Let's go.
Shoshone.
Some strangers there, very strange.
They come here in peace.
Tababone! Tababone!
He says there are white men.
Untrue.
That one there, he is not white.
They speak with forked tongue.
Made them go away.
They never saw a white man.
I have come with a message of peace and friendship
from your white brothers of the great American nation.
Been a long time.
Horses, can you supply them?
He agrees, but they are poor.
You have to pay them.
Yes, Chief, all right.
For that old horse, I'll give you one buckskin shirt and a knife.
Just one rifle, I won't pay more.
Price keeps going up. Let's quit.
Farther to the top?
Sure. No man's ever gone up.
Freeze. We'll make a nice fire.
There's no game and we've run out of food.
Nothing to do now but die, I guess.
W-what do we do now?
View to our village.
He he he he.
Why, you would yell 'em.
The Great, they will aid us in making canoes.
The Great Pond? Hmm.
The Great Southern Sea. Pacific, you call it.
No need for boats. I invented one.
I forgot. Come, I'll show you.
Jews there are safer at birth, stays flat, curious custom, we do a play, it's not peaceful now, my dream, give me your knife, here, Clark had found the Northwest Passage, a land route to the Pacific, they were men of goodwill, and they promised the Indian tribes, in the name of the Americans, peace and friendship for all time, but that peace wasn't to last long.